The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen-only mode.
Hey, good morning everybody. It's Mike
from Order Flows. I hope everyone's
having a a great great day today. It's
June 8th. It's almost summer already and
you know, people always say, you know,
ah, the summer doldrums in the market.
There's not much going on, but you know,
in actuality, it's markets are active
pretty much every day and you know,
there's so many markets you have out
there to choose from that, you know, as
a as a trader, you have, you know,
plenty of opportunities. And don't sort
of fall into this thing like summertime,
you know, the the markets are going to
get quieted down and you know, this not
going to give me any opportunities for
making money in trading. There's always
opportunities every day, you know, the
market is open. There's always going to
be opportunities. And what we'll be
talking about today is mastering order
flow and how you can improve your
trading results, you know, with order
flow. Okay, I mean, that's why we're all
here because, you know, we want to
become better traders. And you know, you
never reach a plateau in your trading,
right? You always want to keep improving
yourself. You know, markets are dynamic.
They're always um you know, evolving.
And you know, same with you know, sorts
of analysis out there. There's There's
new ways to approach the market and
today I'm going to talk about, you know,
understanding market dynamics through
order flow analysis.
How to use order flow to identify
potential trading opportunities.
I'll talk about strategies for managing
risk using order flow data. You know, at
the end of the day you know, as a
trader, you want to try and make as much
money as possible and you know, risk
management or as I like to call it trade
management is something that is going to
be very useful with the order flow,
right? Order flow allows you to um you
know, let trades run longer. Everyone
always says, you know, you got to let
your winners
run, cut your losers short, but they
don't really talk about how to
let your winners run and I'll be
explaining how you could use order flow
to help you let your trades that are in
the money go further. Okay?
So
uh where am I here?
Who I am. If you're new to one of my
presentations, I'll just give you a a
quick brief background on myself and my
name is Michael Valtos. I
started a company in around 2015. It's
called orderflows.com and what it is
it's an order flow based software and
education
uh package. But prior to that, I had
over 20 years of professional futures
trading experience, right? I started on
the CME floor with Dean Witter.
And I was on the floor for about 2 years
on the Chicago Mercantile Exchange and
electronic trading was just starting. It
was in its infancy. And
you know, the company I was working for
said you know, hey, we need some guys to
uh sit upstairs, you know, run the
electronic trading uh machines do the
trading and you know, being a young guy
in my 20s at the time
I'm like, hey, yeah, I'll you know, I
raised my hand. You know, nobody wanted
to do it because at that time to trade
electronically it was outside of the
floor session. So it was basically from
um you know, 4:00 p.m. Chicago time
until 8:15 in the morning. So you'd
either be working in the evenings or the
overnights. I had the
fortune of of working the overnight
session from about 11:00 p.m. until 8:15
in the morning and it was great because
I saw the rev the evolution, rather, of
electronic trading and how to understand
the flow of orders coming in there on
the machine you know, basically from the
very beginning. And after about 3 years
of that, I left. I joined another
company, EDF Man, a big English trading
company uh in their Chicago office for
about 2 years.
After that, I joined Commerzbank, the
big German bank um where I I specialized
in bonds bobbles, Schatz, DAX and Euro
Stoxx.
And after that, I spent about 4 years
with Cargill. Cargill's a big commodity
trading company um in the US. You know,
they account for about 30% of grain
exports and about 25% of meat exports,
but they trade everything as well. You
know, anything that grows or can be uh
taken out of the ground they trade. And
you know, they sent me overseas to work.
I worked in Singapore for a year then I
joined JP Morgan in Singapore where I
spent almost almost, you know, 8 and 1/2
almost 9 years as a vice president of
futures trading on the trading desk, you
know, not just sitting in a corner
office looking at spreadsheets saying,
oh, you know, he's his risk is too much.
No, this is the actual trading desk. So
you know, it's through all these jobs
and experiences. Now, you know, it's not
a lot. It's only five years over
I'm sorry, five companies over 20 years.
So it's not like, you know, just jumping
around or
say you know, trading for myself, you
know, no, I I traded professionally. I
traded big size and what I'll be talking
about today is things that I learned
over these years of electronic trading
from the time when it first started, you
know, up until the present time. And
I've I've experienced, you know, the
market rallies, the market crashes, you
know, the financial crash um you know,
the long-term capital management, you
know, the dot-com bubble.
Been through all that. And you know, it
shapes about you know, my my thinking
and how I approach order flow. It's not
just trading from, you know, COVID till
now. No, you know, I traded
bull markets, bear markets um you know,
and crashes.
So as a professional former trader who's
worked on the institutional trading desk
for over 20 years, I'm excited to share
these experiences with you. Right? These
strategies that I'll talk about today
you know, help experienced traders
identify trends in the market and
capitalize on them.
And
if you're a beginner to order flow
right? It's a way to safely conduct your
trading. Okay? And I'm going to show you
ways that you could simply read the
market that's going to help keep you in
trades longer.
Right? And maybe help you cut losing
trades shorter.
Right? Because you know, it's that's
essential for you know, a trader to
understand what's happening in the order
flow
in order to be more successful. Right?
Being successful isn't just about having
good trades. You also got to recognize
when trades are going against you and
cut those.
Okay? So
what's unique is I'm only one of a
handful of former institutional traders
who have mastered both trading order
flow
and teaching it to retail traders all
over the world. Like I said, you know,
I've been doing this for 8 years. You
know, I've been doing this since
2015. What are we? 2023 now? Yeah,
that's that's 8 years. And you know,
it's it's a big difference when you are
a institutional trader versus a retail
trader.
Right? Everyone talks about the size,
but you know, as retail traders I'm in
that retail trading category now cuz I
just trade for myself.
And basically what we are reading, we
are reacting to what the big traders are
doing. So we have to be aware and be
able to understand what they're doing in
the market and take advantage of it.
Okay? So yeah, before we dive in,
a brief disclaimer. Right?
Understand that trading involves risk.
Okay? And you shouldn't trade
without risk capital. Right? Don't think
that oh, you got to pay your your
mortgage you know, at the end of the
month and you got 3 weeks, so you got to
start trading and and make up the
market. You know, don't put yourself in
that position. You're you're putting
yourself at a disadvantage. You know,
it's better to when you start trading
you know, trade with money that
is not where let me just put it this
way, where money isn't going to be in
the forefront of your mind. Right? When
you're trading you know, that's the
money is the afterthought. Right? The
money will come if once you're
consistent and a good trader.
So the first thing I'll talk about is
understanding market dynamics through
order flow analysis.
So what is market dynamics? Well,
it's basically the forces of
the market constituents, the traders
that are responsible for the shift in
the demand and supply curve and
basically are accountable for creating
or reducing supply and demand of a
particular product. Basically, market
dynamics is supply and demand. You know,
it sounds fancy like, you know, this I
took off of some um website. You know,
this is this is the
academic
description or definition of market
dynamics. But at the end of the day
market dynamics is just the
tug-of-war between supply and demand
which is going on between the buyers and
sellers in the market.
Now
when we talk about you know, the trading
that's taking place. Okay?
We just think in the basic sense of, you
know, buyers and sellers. Right? We
don't we don't think about the types of
buyers and sellers that are there in the
market. But there's actually
two forms of buyers and sellers, two
forms of traders. Right? You have
aggressive traders, you have passive
traders. And
this is an important distinction when
you're looking at a market, especially
when you're looking at order flow
because you want to know, you know, are
the aggressive traders
you know, very active or are the passive
traders also you know, taking control of
the market in a way. I mean, they're
passive. You don't necessarily think of
them taking control, but really what you
see is them absorbing, right? The
passive traders will absorb. And the
difference is aggressive traders are the
ones who pay market price or sell at the
market.
Okay, they are that's why they're
aggressive, right?
And passive traders are the orders that
are sitting in the order book that the
aggressive traders trade against. And
you know, while it sounds
fancy, big words, aggressive traders,
passive traders, really think of it in
simple everyday terms. Okay, if you're
if you are looking to buy a house
and you have to buy it, like and you're
willing to pay market price or above
market price,
you would be the aggressive buyer.
If you own the house and you want to
sell it
and you want to sell it, you know, maybe
you want to sell it for a million, but
you think I can get a million one, you
list it at a million one and you just
wait for someone that's going to come
along and pay a million one, you would
be the passive seller.
Now,
if you're a motivated seller, meaning I
got to get rid of this house, you know,
my
for whatever reason, you know, my
business is failing, I got to sell my
house to cover expenses and someone
comes in and
says, you know, I'll buy your house, but
I'll pay 900,000 for it.
Now, that buyer, he's the passive buyer.
And if you're going to sell it to him at
900,000, you're going to be the
aggressive trader, you're going to be
the aggressive seller.
Cuz now you're selling your house at
price that's the current bid.
Essentially, you're selling at the
market.
Sorry.
Now, once you're able to distinguish
between aggressive traders and passive
traders,
you're going to get information in the
order flow.
And
there's three building blocks of order
flow
that in my opinion, you know, all the
information that you need, sort of not
all of it, but majority is originates
from. It's delta, it's point of control
and it's imbalances.
Now, delta is simply the difference
between the aggressive buyers and the
aggressive sellers in a bar. Now, you
can have cumulative delta, which is, you
know, for the day,
um you know, you can have delta for a
time period, but generally when we talk
about delta, we're talking about, you
know, specific
bar, right? Cuz we look at, you know,
price charts that are broken down by
either time or by volume or ticks or you
know, however you break down your bar.
So, each bar will have a delta. It's
either going to be positive, meaning
aggressive buyers were in control, or
it'll be negative, meaning aggressive
sellers were in control.
Once in a while, the delta will be at
zero. Not once in a while, but very
rare. But it does happen and it's more
of coincidence when that happens cuz,
you know, it could easily be minus one
or plus five. It's just that it happened
and landed at zero. So, I I I don't read
too much into it if it's exactly at
zero, meaning
buyers and sellers aggressive buyers,
aggressive sellers
were evenly matched, but um you said
it's just more of coincidence if it
lands on zero. Okay, but I'm going to
talk about delta uh shortly. Now, point
of control, all right, point of control,
every bar has a point of control.
Now, if you're familiar with market
profile, volume profile, point of
control should be something you're
familiar with, you know, which is the
price level for the day where the most
volume traded. But you can actually
break it down by
by bar. So, if you're looking at a
one-minute bar chart, each bar, all
right, is going to have volume
distributed within that bar. And that
price level that has the most volume is
the point of control. If you're looking
at a uh
you know, uh
5,000 volume bar, there's going to be a
price level in that bar where the most
volume transacts. That's going to be
your point of control. So, it doesn't
matter, you know, whether you're looking
at a time-based chart, uh tick-based
chart, a volume-based chart, etc.
Cuz within that bar, just as within a
day of a volume profile, volume is going
to be distributed. Okay, and it's just
simply
the price level with the most volume
traded on both the bid and the offer.
Now, the third point is imbalances,
okay? And imbalances in the order flow
is when you have more aggressive buying
than selling by a certain percentage,
right? Four to one is is sort of the
industry standard. Some people use three
to one, some use, you know, five to one,
but sort of the the
for me, I use four to one. That is, you
know, it's just it's it's a nice level
because you know that one side is
dominating the other. So, an aggressive
a buying imbalance is when you have more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers. A selling imbalance is the
opposite, when you have more aggressive
sellers than aggressive buyers by four
to one.
So, from these three, delta, point of
control and imbalances,
excuse me,
you're going to be able to get a lot of
information that you can make trading
decisions off of.
And if you're looking at a normal bar
chart,
okay?
You're going to see there's areas like
here. I've I've highlighted two areas
where you see the market, you know,
reversed. And if you're looking at these
areas
on a bar chart, they're they're kind of
nondescript.
You don't understand why a market turned
at one level and sold off to a level
then rallied up from it. But when you
understand the order flow, you will
understand why the market stopped there.
Okay?
And this right here is that first circle
right up here. Okay? See how the market
was going up? It sort of stalled up
here, then it sold off and it was a nice
sell-off
of over 10 points
and it happened, you know, within about
uh 20 to 30 minutes.
And the easiest clue that you would get
is simply by watching the order flow.
Okay? So, what's happening, right? The
market was going up, all right? Remember
on the bar chart, right? Market was
going up nice and sharp. Nice rise, then
it sort of stalled, then it sold off.
Well, what was the signs? Well, as
you're going up making these highs up
here,
all right? You sort of
yeah, you got the one big green bar,
right? Which is what you expect to see
as the market's going up.
Nice big positive delta, big green bar.
Then you go a little bit higher and the
aggressive selling starts coming in. You
can see you got the negative delta.
Okay?
And that's a sign.
It's your first sign of some weakness in
the market. And then the next bar, a
nice green bar up again, matches, you
know, the same high of the bar. It's got
positive delta, 300. Okay, that's what
you like to see. So, you know, maybe
there's something more to this move
that's still going on.
And then it comes up here, makes a
slightly new high by about a point.
Still got positive delta, but it's
getting lesser.
Okay, so you're going up here, making a
new high, making a new high, but as
you're doing it, the volume is,
actually, the delta is getting weaker.
All right, it made this first high with
negative delta, so it's telling you
aggressive selling came in.
And then it sort of
paired up that high and then the next
high here,
it's got weaker delta, all right? It had
positive 322 and then it's down to only
233.
And then it can't even go any higher. It
gets within a tick of the high and it's
got a small positive delta.
Okay?
And then the next bar is a red candle
down and it's got a negative delta. So,
let's think about it, all right? Let's
take a step back and take a look here.
So, we're going up, right? Nice
aggressive buying, right? Just by
watching the delta.
Go up here, negative delta. It's a sign
sellers are coming in. And then I mean,
that's your first sign. Maybe people
were taking some profit, you know,
hitting the bid, just getting out,
taking their profit up here cuz we just
had a nice little rally.
And then we start going trying to go
higher, but as we're going higher, the
aggressive buying, you can see, is
getting weaker.
322 is the aggressive amount of
aggressive buyers. Make the new high,
233. Then the next bar, it can't even
make a new high and it's got a very
small delta of positive 11. So, it's
just telling you that there's more
there's only 11 more aggressive buyers
than sellers in that bar. And then the
next bar, a big strong negative delta,
373. So, you know, if you're looking at
this bar chart, you can't necessarily
tell that buying is getting weaker as
you're going up, but by watching the
order flow, simply looking at the delta,
you can see that, right? Because you
know, I mean, it's simple, just looking
at
the amount of aggressive buying
that's taking place or in this case, the
amount of aggressive buying that is
weakening,
what do you think's going to happen if
there's no more aggressive buyers? Well,
if there's no more aggressive buyers,
who's there to take the market higher?
Well, no one, right? And then the market
sells off.
Okay, then it gets down here. Okay, this
is around the 11:00 the same day.
All right, let's go back here.
All right? We rallied, then we sold off
to this area, all right? Then we bounced
back up again.
Okay, well, what's what's happening down
what's happening down there?
As you're coming down, you know, nice
aggressive selling, negative deltas
here, you know, minus 589, minus 964,
minus, you know, 490. It bounces up a
little bit, then comes down here.
Minus 554, minus 670, minus 785, minus
93, minus 21.
And then plus 650.
So, it's coming down here.
Nice strong sellers, minus 589,
minus 964, minus 500, minus 600, minus
700. Then only minus 90,
minus 21.
Okay?
Where's my where's my sellers?
They're not there anymore. They've sold
everything that they need to sell for
now.
Okay, then you see the aggressive buyers
coming in here with a strong positive
delta
and the market starts to rally again.
So, that's you know, a simple way to use
delta
to clue you in on what's happening with,
you know, the intensity of buying or
selling that's taking place in the
market, right? Cuz at the end of the
day,
you know, for a move to continue, you
need buyers for the move to continue up,
you need aggressive sellers for the move
to continue down. And if they're not
there,
that move's not going to continue.
Okay.
You know, here market drives down and
then it reverses back up, right? Comes
back up to the previous high
from where we had just sold off of.
And it's one of these things where you
get that big sharp move down, very quick
move down and then quick move up. You
know, people that are
you know, they see this move start to
happen, everyone's getting short, but
then you had a very sharp reversal here.
Well,
if you're looking at the order flow, you
can see how it just shifts on you
very quickly.
Okay, market's coming down, right? The
red bar, the red bar, then you had this
green bar.
Well, what's happening? Okay, you got
the strong negative delta, minus 1,100.
Another bar, strong negative delta,
minus 1,100.
Then you get down here, you got
aggressive selling,
right? You can see the 476, the red
numbers within the bar is
how you determine the imbalances. So,
that if it's red, you could see in the
two-way auction, it's a selling
imbalance, or if it's blue, it's a
buying imbalance, okay?
And so, you see this the aggressive
selling taking place, the strong
negative deltas.
Even down here, you see more aggressive
selling, selling imbalance, selling
imbalance, then the market reverses, the
aggressive buying just sort of comes in
here almost out of nowhere
with one buying imbalance, two, three,
four, even if in the next bar, one, two,
three buying imbalances. And you can see
how the delta shifted actually
from a a strong
negative to a strong positive within
this bar.
If you're looking at the max delta and
the min delta, these are market internal
delta readings, so I could see at one
point this green candle that's up,
that's got a positive delta 400,
actually had a negative delta
of minus 471.
So, early in this bar, obviously it was
red, it was a red candle down, you see
the selling imbalances in here.
And a nice strong negative delta
forming, minus 471.
Then it reversed, the aggressive buying
came in, that's how you can tell, you
know, that's a clear sign of a of you
know, aggressive trading is imbalances.
And then the delta turns positive, so it
went from minus 400 back to zero,
which is a swing of 400, and it finished
at 400, so it's actually swing of 800 in
the delta,
right? So, you know, that's that's an
important reading because it's it's one
thing to just have a delta of of 400,
but you went from a strong negative
to a strong positive, right? Then you
couple that in with the
buying imbalances, I mean, the four
buying imbalances in there, and you know
the aggressive traders were strong.
Okay?
Here's another one that, you know,
you can see this move, right? It's going
up.
Up, up, up, up. Okay, you people say,
"Well, you have some selling imbalances,
isn't that, you know, bearish?" Well,
here on this move up at the top of this
bar, actually what you have is strong
bids coming in
to support the market going up.
It reaches its pinnacle up here, and
what do you see? You start seeing a lot
of aggressive selling as the market
starts appearing to starts to sell off,
right? You got one, two, three, four,
five imbalances in this bar, two here,
another uh seven, eight in this bar. So,
you can see the aggressive traders
coming in. Obviously, you've got
negative delta, which is what you like
to see, you're going to see negative
delta with imbalances. But the most
obvious one is as we are selling off,
you're looking for bars that have
multiple selling imbalances, you know,
more than three, that's you know, spread
out in the bars, just telling you people
are coming in, they're coming in out of
the woodwork as we made these new highs,
you know, swing highs or or highs of the
day, doesn't matter, but
when a market reaches a certain level,
you know, you you want to see it attract
other traders coming in. And here you
can see it's attracting other traders,
in this case it's attracting aggressive
sellers, it's attracting sellers to the
market. So, if I know that there's
sellers in the market, yeah, to me, I
know this market's going to sell off.
Okay? Now, again, they'll just sort of
talk about these selling imbalances on
the way up,
this is actually liquidity, which I'll
talk about coming, you know, a little
bit later. It's a market that's getting
bid up,
right? When you have, you know, the
green candles with selling imbalances,
that's actually a bullish sign. When you
have red candle with selling imbalances,
that's bearish.
Okay, read between the lines, you know,
this is a famous saying.
Uh I won't get into the origin of it,
but what's happening here, right? You
see this market sort of going up,
getting weaker, and then it has a nice
move down, right? And you know, breakout
traders,
you know, people that follow price
action will see, "Oh, yeah, you broke
this low down here, then you sold off."
Well,
if you're looking at the order flow, you
could have gotten short, you know, five,
three or four points higher than down
here, rather than getting short at the
breakout of this, you know, this this
low down here at 4279 and a half. If
you're reading the order flow, you know,
you could have been getting short around
4380,
4282 and a half.
Why? Just by watching the order flow.
You're sort of coming up here to the
swing high,
and you're seeing,
you know, positive delta 300, okay,
then minus nine,
positive delta of 106, so you went from
300 to 106, okay, then a small negative
delta of minus 43.
And then up here, right at this swing
high here, it's got delta of one.
Okay, so look at just the positive
deltas, 316, 106, one.
Right? Read between the lines.
Even though it's putting in positive
deltas,
it's really dropping off precipitously,
right? It's not going higher with
stronger deltas, it's going higher on
very weak positive deltas.
And then mixed in is obviously negative
deltas.
And then what happens?
You could just see that in here, you
could be getting short 4282, 4282 and a
half, rather than waiting for the market
to break down
and getting short at, you know, 4279,
and a half,
because
this is
you know, this is the profit that you
want to take. Yeah, it's nice to get
this move, but you could be getting in
much earlier on a trade rather than
later by your simply reading what's
happening in the order flow.
Now, point of control,
right? It's the price level in the bar
with the most volume. And again, if
you're looking at a simple bar chart,
you can't see where the volume is,
right? If I'm looking at this
candlestick chart, I don't know where
the volume is anywhere here.
You know, uh people have ways of trying
to say, "Oh, there's an imbalance,
there's something, you know, fair value
gaps, etc."
You know, that's you you you you're just
guessing, right? When you use those
terms, because you're not looking at the
actual volume. That's why, you know,
order flow is
is so important because it tells you
where things are trading and the
intensity of the trading, the strength
or the lack
of strength. It's not just about looking
at where volume occurs, you also want to
be looking at where lack of volume
occurs.
So, on an order flow chart, you're going
to see
a price level in a bar
where the most volume is.
And there's certain point of controls
that matter,
that have importance, you know, every
bar is going to have a point of control,
but it doesn't necessarily mean
anything. Most bars, it's going to be in
the middle,
right? And when the point of control is
in the middle of the bar, that's your
normal distribution.
What you as a trader want to do is take
advantage of
the abnormal distribution,
right?
If you're looking in here, you can see
how the market sort of came down,
bounced up, came down, bounced up, and
then sold off.
Okay, why?
Cuz the volume is starting to be
distributed at the edge of the bars,
telling you that there's sellers coming
in
you know, at the high of the bar. So,
what's happened is, you know, it sort of
came down here, went back up, came down,
looks like it was about to rally,
and then at the top of this bar, all the
volume, uh not all the volume, the
majority of the volume is taking place
there.
So, it's telling me that buyers are
coming in, you know, as this market is
starting to drop down, they're coming in
at these levels saying, "Hey, you know,
this we think that this price is a good
sell." Right? And then they've got
volume, too, sort of absorb whatever
aggressive buying is going to take place
and sell it up here because they're
anticipating lower prices.
And just really quick, you know,
if there was one way, people ask me, you
know, "What's the simplest way to trade
order flow?"
I just say, you know, trade the point of
controls that are on the extreme of
bars. And what that means is on a red
candle
at the top price level or on a green
candle at the very bottom price level.
Instead of that if you just want one way
to start trading order flow,
just look for those
and trade around them, okay?
Because you can see here, right? This
market was going up, pulls back.
Volume steps in down here on this
pullback.
You know, people always talk about
buying the dip. Those are the dips you
want to buy when there's strong buyers
coming in.
You know, to sort of arrest the move
down. You don't want to be buying a dip
and the market keeps dipping. You want
to buy a dip where it stops at and then
starts rallying.
Right? And if you're looking at point of
control, again, on a bar chart, you
don't see where it is.
It's impossible to see it on a normal
bar chart. You need order flow.
Because, you know, this is
a couple days ago in the gold, right? It
was
on the order flow, there's a great
reason to buy this pullback right here,
you know, before it rallied up.
But if you're looking on a simple bar
chart, you're not going to see it.
And it's going to give you the better
entry rather than buying up here or even
buying up here. It's going to give you
this nice entry
to hold it.
Whoops.
That is this chart right here. That's
this bar right here. This point of
control on the extreme. Right? I know
there's strong volume coming in here to
stop whatever move is taking place. You
know, you could get long in the next
bar, right? In somewhere in here
or even within the next couple of bars.
You can see it takes
basically it doesn't even test that
level, right? That's right here.
You'd be getting long here or here or
here
rather than somewhere over here. And
again, you're not taking any pretty much
any heat on this trade. It you know,
you're not going down into drawdown at
all.
And then you get that big move up.
Now, keep it in context.
Right? Just because you have a point of
control, you know, don't run out and
say, "Oh, I got to trade every single
um green bar that has a point of control
on the bottom or sell every single red
bar that has a point of control on the
top." Take it in context, right? You
want to do it on a pullback rather than,
you know, after you have a big move and
then you get the the volume appearing at
the bottom, right? That's not what you
want to do. After a move up, you'd be
looking for a reason to sell, right?
You'd be looking for the red candle with
the point of control somewhere near the
top, not a green bar at a high with a
point of control on the bottom.
Okay? So,
let's move on to the next part. How do
you use order flow
to identify potential trading
opportunities?
So, let's look at the market, right? I
showed you this chart again, so it's
cheating, but you know, where is the
trade?
Right? Is it here on the breakout? No,
it's here on the order flow, right? You
can see as we're going up, the order
flow is weakening.
316, 106, one in the positive deltas and
you still got the negative deltas. Even
if you're looking at the negative
deltas, it went from minus nine, minus
43,
minus 251. So, not only do you have the
positive deltas increasing,
or sorry, decreasing from three 316 to
106 to one, you have the negative deltas
increasing from minus nine, minus 43,
minus 251.
So, you don't have to wait till the
market breaks down over here to get
short. You can just get short in here.
And where's your risk? It's just right
above the swing high. Getting short down
here, your stop is still the same price,
but this in this case you're getting in
much closer,
much earlier to your stop price.
Okay?
Here's another great example, right? You
can see this market is just sort of
going sideways in here.
But look at this little collection of
bars
that we have right in here.
Right? As this market is going sideways,
we've got strong aggressive selling,
strong negative deltas. Minus 625,
minus 637, minus 661.
Then minus 21,
but strong selling, strong selling,
strong selling, strong selling.
The market's not going down.
So, what what's that telling you, right?
You got to read and understand,
you know, the order flow is, okay, I've
got strong selling in the market.
Market's not going down. Maybe it's a
sign of absorption. People are coming in
to absorb that aggressive selling.
And then what happens? Rather than get
short saying, "Oh, there's all this
aggressive selling, I got to get short."
You see the negative deltas. I got to
get short. Well, if you do, the market
rallied. But by reading it, by
understanding that, you know, I got
strong aggressive selling taking place,
but the market's not going down. Okay?
Maybe someone's absorbing it, right? You
got to be able to make that distinction.
So, you get rewarded saying, "Oh,
there's absorption going on down here. I
can join that absorption. I can try and
get long at these lower levels."
Cuz if that absorption holds, the
market's going to go up. And what's your
risk? It's just below that level of
absorption. That is how
supply and demand works, right? You want
to be buying
you know, when there's
uh say demand in the market, you know,
think of it rather than supply demand. I
sorry, I should use the words uh support
resistance, right? Cuz you know,
sometimes people confuse support and
resistance with supply and demand. They
use it interchangeably.
But in this case, you're buying at
support.
And then eventually, you know, you you
would sell at resistance, right? Being
able to identify support is through
absorption.
Okay, here's a nice chart, right? This
is gold, right? Gold is is a is a
wonderful market for trading. You get
nice price movements.
But again, you can see it here, right?
You're just watching what's happening
as the market's coming up, positive
delta, positive delta. It gets small as
185, 150, then just 19.
Then it turns negative at your swing
high, minus 38, minus 141, minus 63. And
on the way up, you got the aggressive
buying, right? With the imbalances in
the bars.
Then it sort of it turns up here on the
red candle. Point of control is matched,
you know, as you're going higher,
points of controls
are also moving higher, which is what
you like to see because, you know, if a
market is moving up, you want to see
volume also trading higher, looking for
more volume to trade. That that's a sign
of a
of a healthy move up. And then as the
market goes down, you're seeing the
aggressive selling coming in with the
imbalances. And you're starting to see
the point of controls go lower, lower,
lower, lower, lower, lower.
Right? Because now sellers
are looking for
areas that they can sell more and more
volume at,
you know, at at lower uh they're not
looking to sell at lower prices, but as
the market is going down, they have to
start selling at lower prices. And
they're going to start getting a bit
aggressive and that's how you see
um in the selling imbalances.
Okay? Now,
one of the things that really, in my
opinion, make makes order flow so
special is
you can see where the liquidity is. And
you know, liquidity is basically the
passive buyers and the passive sellers.
Well, most traders don't even think
about what the passive buyers or passive
sellers are doing.
And, you know, we had this big sell-off
in the gold yesterday,
right?
20 point, you know,
30 almost 30 point move down.
And, you know, while it's nice to have a
reason to sell up here, you know, if you
have any reason to be selling on this
move down, that's great. And by looking
at liquidity, looking at where the
passive sellers are coming in and what
is a passive seller? It's it's somebody
with supply
you know, supply in the market coming in
to offer it out. They're trying to sell
it. They're trying to get rid of it.
They don't want to just come in and hit
the bid and help move the market lower.
They're going to help offer resistance
in the market. Okay? And this here is
was a very clear sign, this little
circled area,
was a very clear sign of liquidity
coming into the market.
Right? And let's take a closer look.
Now, you know,
on this move down,
right? People that trade price action,
"Oh, you got a bullish pin bar here. Oh,
you got another one right here. I got to
be getting long." You buy this one,
stop out. You buy this one, stopped out,
right? Pin bars are supposed to you
know, even some you know, one up here,
right? Everyone's going to say, "Oh, you
got a bullish pin bar. You got you got
to buy those." Well,
this is where using order flow is going
to help you because if you buy those,
watching what's happening in the order
flow will tell you, "Hey, you know, I I
got to get out of this trade."
rather than let it stop me out. And
again, you know, candlesticks are nice.
I like I I look at candlesticks, but I
understand that, you know,
candlestick patterns don't always work.
You know, maybe you get
you know, there's been studies done over
the years, you know, some candlesticks
have, you know, 68% chance or, you know,
47% chance. But when you start adding it
with order flow,
it's going to really one, keep you out
of bad trades, or two,
get you out of losing trades a lot
sooner. That's
At the end of the day, it's going to
help you as a trader. That's how you cut
your losses by looking at what's
happening in the order flow.
And I can see it right here, right? So,
this market was coming down, bounced up,
starts going down.
And I can see the liquidity coming in
here, 177 contracts. And then in this
red candle, 105. It's coming in on the
offer. Now, these are areas that at the
market had just been trading at. You
know, just a few minutes before and in
this case, you know, 30 seconds before.
So, if I know the market's coming down,
bounces up, I got someone came in in
here and offered out, you know, 177
contracts. You know, even though
somebody bought it, market did go back
up. Okay, next thing I know we're
trading below it. And then this one
here, right? As this market is starts
going lower,
I can see there was a big seller here,
105 contracts.
And on the bar chart, you know, it's
just right there as this market is
starting to go lower. So, if I know that
there's liquidity coming in here
on the sell side,
I don't want to be long.
I I'd rather be short than
anything, you know, rather than cover my
position and and sit on the sidelines.
I'd I'd be looking to sell the heck out
of this to catch the rest of that move
down because now I know there's a big
seller coming into the market. It's time
for me to to also get short.
That's how you can trade liquidity,
right? You don't necessarily need a heat
map or a book map. You know, people like
to use those now and there's nothing
wrong with it. It's a tool at the end of
the day.
And, you know, but if you're looking at
order flow, you can see things like that
taking place because,
you know, really what you want to be
looking at is the actual trades that
take place, not necessarily orders
coming in, right? Oh, you know, cuz
you're going to see as this market sells
off, there'll be bids below, offers
above. What you want to see is where
that's trading at. You know, is it
trading right now? Cuz you're trading in
the now. You're not trading in the
future.
Now, strategies for managing risk using
order flow data, right? And I explained
that earlier, right? Think of it as, you
know, not necessarily managing risk, but
managing your trade.
You know, you want to be able to
cut your losers short, let your winners
run. That's the whole point of trading,
right? Risk management. That's how you
going to maximize your profits and
limit your losses.
And you can see here just by watching
the order flow. Again,
it's it's not it's not rocket science,
right? You can see the market coming up
here topping.
What's happening in the deltas? What's
happening in the imbalances, right? You
can see, okay, you have positive delta,
the market goes up, right? Aggressive
buyers. Then it just sort of spins its
top right here.
You know, you got you know, positive
delta. Then you start seeing the
the aggressive selling coming in with
the negative deltas, right? Because
remember, right? Everyone, you know, Jim
Dalton talks about price being an
advertising mechanism. So, think about
it, right? Market had been going up.
It rallied about 10 points pretty
quickly.
Now it's at these new higher levels,
people are reacting. They're saying,
"Hey, you know what? This is a great
place to sell."
And they come in, they start selling.
Right? And you can see it happening in
the order flow. The
negative deltas are getting stronger,
right? Right off the high here, minus
117, then minus 300, minus 500.
Points of controls are going lower and
then the market starts to sell off.
Right? This is a sign of a market
bottoming. It's sort of the opposite
effect, right? Cuz market is selling
off, you got the strong negative deltas,
minus 500, minus 900,
you know, minus 400 and then again,
minus 600, minus 700, then just minus
93, minus 21. Okay, where's my
aggressive sellers? They're gone. This
is the type of action that you see daily
you know, when markets are bottoming,
either, you know, could be swing bottoms
or markets are making highs or highs of
the day or or swing highs, the topping
act- activity and the bottoming
activity.
Now, that doesn't mean every single top
or bottom is going to look exactly like
this,
but when you see that in the market,
that's your sign to take advantage of
that trade.
Or if you're in a trade, if you're short
and you see this activity taking place
in the market,
rather than wait for the market to start
rallying back up and then you know, you
you start moving your stop down, you
know, your take profit, you know, cuz
you're you're not going to hit your take
profit. If you, you know, if you're
short from 4290
and you got a take profit at 4275, which
is just below this low, and you start
seeing this activity take place,
chances are we're not going to go to
your take profit. So, what do you got to
do, right? You have a take profit in the
market, you have a stop. Most people
will start moving their stop down. Okay,
then eventually get stopped on this
bounce. But if you're seeing this
activity take place, well, you can move
your your take profit from, you know,
75, you know, maybe you're going to move
it up to 76, 76 and a half, 77, rather
than chase it back up here. And then
eventually it, you know, you're short
from 90 and then your your stop
you move it down to 82. You So, you you
make
eight points of profit
cuz you never hit your take profit. You
you still had a profit of of eight
points, but where would you rather be
getting out?
At 82
or at 78?
Right? Well, you that's an extra four
points you're leaving on the table. If
you just like, "Well, okay, well, you
know, my my
my stop for my profit is, you know, it's
going to get me out at 82. I'm happy
with that." Well, I'd be much happier
adjusting my take profit up to, you
know,
a more reasonable level.
You know, cuz you know, even if even if
it's at 79, you move your take profit
from 75 up to 79 as it starts coming
back up cuz you read what was happening
in the order flow, rather than moving
your
you know, your stop down to get out, you
know, up over here at 82. That's three
points. Three points in the S&P's is
$150.
And again, you know, you're short. This
is gold. Again, this is that gold move
yesterday. You know, I put this chart in
here because it it's easy to see, right?
Everyone always has this plan. Well,
yeah, I'm going to either get long or
get short, but say you're short in this
move,
right? And you read what's happening in
the order flow. Some people would would
get out here.
Then if they get out here, they miss the
rest of this move down because even
though you have a little bit of buying
going on because, you know,
you don't know it when it's, you know,
at 10:20, you don't know if this
market's going to go up or get or keep
going down.
Right? Or maybe you don't know. Maybe
you want to get long or you want to get
short. What do you do?
Well, you would stay short,
right? Because even though this market
is bouncing up, you can see the the
strong selling coming in, right? That's
why I talk about the intensity. That's
why looking at volume is going to help
you because you can see it's not just
aggressive selling coming in. It's quite
strong. It's minus 141.
Right? It's minus 63.
Right? It's not, you know,
minus 12 in the deltas. It's quite
strong. People are coming in here and
they're just whacking all the bids. The
aggressive sellers are strong and and
knowing that information,
if you're Oops. Go back here. If you are
short,
you can stay short,
right? If you got long in here,
you got to get out. Maybe even get
short.
Okay? So, that that's how order flow is
going to help you.
Okay, here, this one is is a little bit
more difficult cuz you don't know yet,
right? What are you going to do?
Okay, maybe you're a long from here.
What if you're a long already, you know,
in here and market was going up and it
comes back down to your your
break even point.
Well, do you you stay in the trade?
You know, is it going to go up? Is it
going to go down? You don't know. Or is
it going to go sideways? Right? Or maybe
you're getting short already from, you
know, up here. Market starts coming
down. Then it's just going sideways.
What do you do? Well, you got to read
the order flow.
In this case,
it continued down. And what were the
signs?
Now, this is a little bit nuanced, okay?
But you still have strong aggressive
selling. Now, people will say, "Well,
you have aggressive buying, these blue
numbers in here, blue, blue, blue,
blue."
Okay. Well, yeah, you have aggressive
buying. Market's not going any higher.
It's being absorbed by a passive
sellers. What are passive sellers? I
talked about that earlier. Passive
sellers are is traders that have supply
they're trying to sell. So, if I know
there's sellers that have supply that
they're trying to sell,
I want to be on their side. I don't want
to be fighting them. You know, if if
someone's got a lot of supply to sell,
well, I'm not going to buy it all. I'm
just, you know, trading a couple
contracts.
I can't I don't have enough to beat
them. They're going to beat me.
And they did, right? That's what
happened.
Right? Boom, the bottom fell out, the
rug got pulled, and the market dropped,
you know, another 10 points, you know,
rather quickly.
Okay?
And again, it's about helping you manage
the trade. This is crude oil. All right?
And
again, you can see, right? Market went
up, it starts coming down.
Right? You want to catch as much as the
move as possible.
And when you start to put it all
together, it's going to help keep you in
the trade, right? This market is moving
down. What do you see? Clear sign
in the bar, looking at the point of
controls. Every point of control is
pretty much lower than the previous one.
So, you know, volume is migrating lower.
As volume goes lower,
price also goes lower. So, it's not just
price going down, you know, cuz price
could go down on light volume. It
doesn't mean anything.
But if price goes down
and the volume is going down, meaning
more and more traders are transacting at
lower prices, probably
it's going to keep going down. Okay,
then you have the selling imbalances on
the way down. You can see two here, one,
one, one, two, you know, one, another
two.
So, you can say, "Okay, not only do I
have volume migrating lower, but I have
aggressive selling coming into the
market." And then obviously
deltas are all red.
Right? Red red red red across the whole
board.
So,
that's how it's going to help you manage
the trade. You know, in this case,
everything was all together. All the
signs were there. Sometimes it's going
to be two pieces. Could be delta and
point of control, or could be delta and
imbalances, or sometimes could be point
of control and imbalances. You could
use, you know, any part of the
information that's available to you. And
the beauty is with order flow, it's all
available to all of us. The information
is there.
You just need
a program
to put it into an easy-to-read format
such as this.
You know, this is what we call the order
flow footprint chart. So, over the last
45-50 minutes, you know, we've covered a
lot of ground. And hopefully now you
know some of the ins and outs of order
flow and how to make smarter trading
decisions.
But unfortunately, I can't cover
everything in in a quick training
session like this. You know, there's so
much more to learn about order flow
trading.
But I hope you that you now have a good
understanding of order flow basics. All
right? You can do it. It's not as
complicated. You know, it's not some
mythical thing. You know, sometimes
traders
yeah, I I see these guys out there, you
know, on on
social media, etc. You know, like they
come up with these fancy names and these
tools. It's just really basically a way
you really it's just simple. Like
trading is reading what's happening in
the market right now, right? And don't
don't think that it's something um you
got to spend years and years learning,
right? You should you can learn this
stuff pretty quick as long as you put
your mind to it.
So, remember, you know, trading can be
daunting for many. But with the right
set of knowledge and strategies, you're
going to learn how to trade with order
flow. And when you join orderflows.com,
I'll share with you my most valuable
trading experiences to guide you and
make sure that your efforts
are are rewarded, right? Because, you
know, you're you're putting in
time and energy into learning order
flow. I want to give you guys, you know,
the leg up, so to speak. So, I got
something special for you. It's It's my
order flows trader software. Now, it
runs on NinjaTrader. And ideally, it's
for futures traders.
If you're interested, go to
orderflows.com/oft6.html. It's
my software. It's my signature software
that I've developed in in 2015.
And we're 8 years into it, and we've got
a lot of tools. I haven't talked about
any of the tools here. I've got about 17
or 18 indicators hardcoded into that
software to help you analyze the order
flow. And I have obviously video
instructions on how you can you know,
what they all mean. And I I want to get
into something in a second. But if
you're interested in the software, go to
orderflows.com/oft6.
There's no monthly recurring payments or
any other payments in the future. Of
course, you'll have to pay for your data
fees and NinjaTrader fees.
But
really what the software does, it's like
plugging a cord into you know, now that
I saw was it yesterday or 2 days ago
Apple released that new goggle thing
um you know,
to surf the internet and do all sorts of
stuff. But really what this order flows
trader software does, it's like plugging
into my brain the analysis that I
normally do,
you can see on your chart in a in a way
because it's going to be highlighted on
your chart, you know, where the market
exhaustion or market weakness or, you
know, which point of controls matter or
where value is, things like that.
So,
if you've ever felt like you're
struggling to understand something only
to have it click into place and suddenly
become easy, that's what I really want
to make the trading experience for you
like. That's the power of understanding
how something works. Once you understand
the underlying principles of anything,
life becomes so much easier. And take
trading for example. If you don't
understand how the markets work,
what makes the markets move, it's going
to be very confusing and frustrating.
Now, the big mistake traders make is
thinking that just having the right
software is all they need to be
successful. They think, "Well, here I
see a software out there and it's
selling for $5,000. I've got to buy that
and I'll become successful." No.
Right? That That's
as far away from the truth as possible.
Because if you don't know how to use the
software, it's not going to do you any
good. That's why I focus on providing
education on how to trade with order
flow. Cuz I want you not only to you
know, have software that helps you, but
understand how to use it, right? Once
you have a solid foundation, then you
can begin trading with confidence. And
that's where the real success starts to
happen. You know, we've all bought
software. And we thought it's going to
change our life. We thought, "Oh, this
is it. This is all I need."
And then we try it. We put it on our
computer. We can't get it you know, we
can't understand what we're looking at,
how to use it. And that's really what I
I do with my software is I want you to
understand how to use it. That's why I
give you extra education.
Right? If you get my software today,
you're going to get access to my order
flow trading course,
which it normally sells for $297. Oh,
you're going to get it for free. Oh,
included in your package. It's the order
flows trading course. It's a 15 hours of
video instruction. This is the the
original course on trading order flow
that many people have copied.
And not only that, you're also going to
get access to my order flows inner
circle video series, which consists of
56 videos on advanced order flow
uh tips and analysis forms of I say
tricks, but really, you know, the
nuances of order flow. And really, the
only way to get access to the order flow
inner circle video series collection is
through this offer. You can't buy it
anywhere.
And if you add up the price of the
software of $899, the training for $297,
the inner circle video series of $497,
it comes out to $1693.
But you're not going to pay that. Okay?
You're going to get a much lower price.
I got a better much better special deal.
Now,
it's one thing to learn from videos and
books. You know, we've all watched
YouTubes on on, you know, how to do
things around the house, how to fix, you
know, I I watched it on how to fix my
garage door. Um
and people
go to YouTube to go watch how to learn
how to trade. But it what I found to be
more helpful is have
live training, you know, where you
can ask questions directly to me in a
live environment. And for the last 3
years, I've been hosting the live user
training sessions for all users to join
where I drive home what I saw in the
order flow the past week, you know,
where you can ask questions to me, you
know, maybe you got an issue with the
software you want me to look at. And,
you know, maybe I missed your email or I
didn't reply. You
I'm there pretty much every week. I
didn't have one 2 days ago because I'm
on the road. But um you know, I've been
doing this for over 3 years. We actually
have over 200 episodes
um over the last 3 years. And it's free
for all users of our software
to attend. And if you can't attend, you
can watch the replays. So, there are
other you know, you I've seen other
software where you could buy the
software and then they charge you how to
use it. I I I I that boggles my mind.
Right? Where someone sells you a
software and says, "Oh, but you want to
use it, you got to pay extra." No, you
should know how to use it. So, I also
I include that for free. I don't charge
you extra on lessons on how to use the
software.
Right? So, what I discussed today
on this training is really just a small
sample of of the kinds of analysis I
talk about
on a weekly basis in the live training
sessions, right? Where I go into much
more detail about all aspects of trading
from, you know, order flow to technical
analysis to fundamental analysis. I also
talk about some of the different trading
strategies I use and how to adapt them
to changing market conditions and much
more. So, if you're serious about
trading, then I highly recommend that
you get started now.
So, you're going to learn more about
order flow in the weekly sessions than
you probably ever thought possible.
You're definitely going to learn more
you know, on on one of the weekly
sessions than you would, you know,
watching 10 hours of video instructions
on on YouTube. Cuz a lot of times you
don't even know what person's talking
about until you're invested in it.
Whereas, you know, in the live sessions,
you can ask your questions.
Now, I got a special bonus
for those of you from Investors Expos is
the order flow playbook, which is a
course that I made. And there's an
additional 10 order flow trade setups
that you can learn in there. Normally, I
sell this for $297. You're going to get
it for free today.
So,
what you're going to get is the order
flows trader six,
which is valued at $899,
the trading course,
which is valued at $297, the inner
circle video series valued at $497, the
weekly live group training session, you
know, again, which some software
companies charge over $200 a month for.
Ridiculous.
And you get access to the order flow
playbook for $297. But total value on
all that is over $2000. It's $2190.
But you're only going to pay $749 today,
right? To get all of that. And it's just
a one-time payment. You don't have to
pay anything extra to me ever again in
regards to the order flows trader
software. Upgrades are free. Again,
we've been providing the software since
2015.
And when NinjaTrader had the big move
from NinjaTrader 7 to NinjaTrader 8,
everyone got the free upgrade. I know a
lot of companies charged for that.
Now, again, you have to pay your
NinjaTrader fees and and your data fees
cuz you do need a real-time data. You
don't need level two, just level one,
which is fine. Again, I get data from
NinjaTrader brokerage.
And I get CME, CBOT, NYMEX, COMEX, and
Eurex.
And I let pay like $60 a month for all
three data fees. I do have level two,
but that's just for me cuz I do like to
look at the depth of market. But
again, level one would cost you probably
a little bit less. It probably cost you
around $50 a month. So, go to
orderflows.com/oft6.html.
I'll put the links in the chat
so that you have access to them. Okay?
So, what's going to do after you go to
orderflows.com/oft6.html,
takes you to this page.
Now, there's a video you can watch on
there.
Um you know, as well as explanations of
all the tools that you're going to get.
Again, I didn't talk about any of the
tools that I just talked about simple
reading the order flow cuz once you
start using the tools that are in the
orderflows trader software,
your mind is going to be blown. So,
scroll down this page.
And just you get to this towards the
bottom, you'll see the buy button here.
Click here to buy now. You're going to
get lifetime access to orderflows trader
six, as well as the access the orderflow
trading course, the inner circle video
series,
access to the weekly live group
trainings, as well as replays, and
access to the orderflow playbook. Now,
once you click here, it takes you to
PayPal. PayPal processes your payment.
I don't get your credit card. Obviously,
I don't I don't want it. I got enough
stuff to deal with myself.
So,
to get started, just go to
orderflows.com/oft6
.html. Now, as a special treat for those
of you guys that have stuck around, I
didn't mention this earlier, but I
actually wrote a book on trading order
flow.
And it's 150 pages. You're not going to
get an actual hard cover copy. You'll
get uh the digital download. But, you
know, I started writing this after I
left my job at JP Morgan in in 20
13.
And
you know, this was sort of my my
contribution back to the trading
community was this was this book. This
was even before I I I didn't want to get
into the software business. Reason I got
into the software business was because
I was trading order flow myself.
And I know that the software
software computer programs are designed
to help you as a trader
or help you with you know, other things.
And
basic order flow analysis, it was just
that. It was basic. And I had my ways of
analyzing the order flow, and I wanted
the software to do that for me. That's
how I ended up getting into the software
cuz
I found a program that understood, you
know, the order flow footprint chart.
And I said, "Hey, can you put this this
this this into the software to help me
with my analysis?" And then I started
sharing my charts with other traders.
And traders like, "Hey, where'd you get
this chart?"
So, what? This is my own chart. This is
what I look at in the order flow. I had
it programmed specifically for me. And
people are like, "Hey, can I can I get a
copy of it?" You know, and eventually,
you know, word started spreading. That's
how we built orderflows.com
into what it is right now.
So, again, you know, to get started,
simply go to
orderflows.com/oft6.html.
And I'll see you guys on the inside. So,
uh everyone has a great rest of their
week.
And stay safe, everyone.
Thanks for attending. Bye-bye.